kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are enjoying
a heavenly getaway and packing on the
pda
i think keep it fresh keep people
interested
the couple's latest getaway appears to
be the exclusive almangiri resort in
utah
the mom of three shared this flirty pic
to instagram on monday
travis holding courtney with her legs
wrapped tightly around his waist
they're passionately smooching oh and we
should also point out that he's
shirtless
and court is slaying in a teeny white
bikini
the caption quote just like heaven
this is such a dream come true the pair
shared more snaps from their utah escape
on their instagram stories
the blink 182 drummer posted the back of
court's head
staring out at the rustic beauty while
court gave us a closer look at their
private backyard complete with a tub
and telescope i love it they also shared
the tour bus they arrived in
court posting this video from inside
watching her sister kim kardashian's
favorite show
bridgeton in bed this is what happens
when one is angry when one burns for
someone who does
not feel the same
you burn for me and get this
kravis is into sexy scrabble
they both posted snaps of the friendly
word game travis making words
like x and orgasm while court stayed on
brand with
vegan girl and oh
abcdefg kravis's utah vacay comes just
weeks after they went all out for
courtney's 42nd birthday
the musician surprised his lady love
with an over-the-top
floral installation in her home entryway
the birthday girl showed off the
romantic gesture on her insta story
tagging travis alongside a black heart
emoji
and writing quote my entire house smells
yummy
i'm just like living life and whatever
happens happens
and travis well he also posted a
birthday tribute to the push founder
sharing this smooched up snap their
fireside cuddle sesh
a corner makeout a pic of her legs
a booty shot some hand holding and
this video a court sucking his thumb
which speaks for itself
anyways seems like kravis is going
strong and
in it for the long haul a source
recently told et that the blink 182
drummer is quote so in love
and infatuated with the reality star and
added that they are having the best time
together
quote he's 100 all in and totally sees a
future with her
courtney is living her best life and is
truly so happy
you